try is the relative word
okay so i first want to really really
really thank the organizers for
inviting us to give a talk about this
because this is the only reason that
last night
just before midnight the paper was
submitted on the archive
so it is going to be online
just give me give me a date and then
okay and the second reason i'm happy to
give this talk is because there are many
people here who
will know much more about what they'll
be talking about so the whole point is
that maybe if we
all get to understand what we need to
understand we can actually do it
so let's see okay so i will
i only have one hour i'll try to be fast
on the
introduction stuff what is the model we
have two players that don't trust each
other they want to do some
secure computation okay so many
different things
what we want to do is create protocols
where they cannot cheat
okay and uh when we look at this model
there are some basic cryptographic
primitives
on which everything else is based so for
example
we talk about bit commitment we talk
about oblivious transfer
the thing that i'll be talking about
today is coin flipping so
it was defined by blub in the early
80s and it's a very simple protocol you
have two players they can send messages
back and forth they want to flip a coin
they don't trust each other who's gonna
flip the coin
okay so hopefully we'll know by the end
who's gonna flip the coin there are two
versions
of coin flipping when we talk about
quantum coin flipping so i just want to
make the distinction
so in the strong coin flipping we want
alice elbow to do a protocol to
communicate with each other
says that at the end there is a random
bit that comes out of the protocol
okay and how do we how do we talk about
cheating we say that alice cannot buy us
the coin neither towards
zero nor towards one with high
probability and the same for bob
okay so they cannot buy us the coin
neither for zero nor for one
any of them okay on the other hand when
we talk about weak coin flipping
then we already assign a value of the
coin which is what
alice wants and what bob wants so we
know from the beginning that alice wants
a zero and bob wants a one
okay and in that case what we what we
what we want is to say that
alice cannot win with probability higher
than fifty percent
in the optimal case and bulk a lot win
with probability higher than
50 on the other hand they could decide
that they want to lose
okay so in the weak point i only
see that alice cannot cheat towards zero
cannot buy us the coin towards zero
which is towards hell
winning the coin and bo cannot buy us
the coin towards one which is his
winning the coin
okay but they could decide alice could
decide that okay i let bob win
the outcome will be one and she can
always do that okay so this is the
difference between strong coin flipping
and weak coin flipping
the weak coin flipping is not that weak
in the sense that if you look at
what was the canonical example of coin
flipping
alice and bob get a divorce who's going
to get the car you kind of know that
they both won the car so a weak coin
flipping would be
good enough to solve this problem okay
for other situations we do need random
coins though
okay so this is the difference between
strong and weak and flipping
what is possible can we do this
primitive so everything is possible
if we assume computational assumptions
classically
so take your favorite one-way function
or heart problem
factoring discrete log so that we're in
a quantum conference
and you can do these things perfectly or
almost perfectly okay
what we'll be talking about here is
information theoretic security so we
don't want to make an assumption about
the power of
alice and bob can we do something so
classically
you can do actually nothing so no matter
what protocol you can devise
one of the two players will always be
able to cheat with probability one
okay so this comes from a min max
theorem and
for neumann's things so
yes both for strong for weak for
basically
any of these forbid commitment for
oblivious transfer for anything
all these things none of these things
are possible information theoretic
theoretically okay and the question was
what about quantum protocols if we allow
alice and bob to communicate with
quantum channels
is something possible okay
so the first results were negative in
the sense that they showed that the
cheating probability cannot be
half so we cannot have perfect coin
flipping neither weak nor
strong these are results by myers and
loinchow
in the mid 90s okay but then
people started looking at coin flipping
more
closely and what the first paper in the
beginning or
in actually 2000 by dorit
showed that there is something that we
can do which is impossible classically
which is that
you can devise a protocol where none of
the two players can cheat with
probability more than 91 percent and
this is for the strong case
okay and then came more protocols
there is a there was a 75 percent
protocol by ambenis
the year after and then in 2003 there
was a very beautiful result that showed
that no matter what you do there is a
lower bound there is a lower bound that
shows that
the cheating cannot be less than one
over square root two
actually what they showed is that the
product of the two cheating
probabilities is always bigger than half
which if you make them equal
it means that you cannot have less than
one over square root two okay
and this is the point where ketavs uh
introduced this formalism of of coin
flippings through sdps and sdp duality
which we will use
as well in order to get the weak coin
flipping protocol so
we'll get back to this and then quite a
few years later with
android ceo we showed that actually this
value is optimal you can achieve this 1
over square root n
sorry one over square root of two
for weak going flipping
so kitaev introduced this formally so
studying
uh these protocols that we'll see and
what's on in 2007 actually showed that
it is possible
so it is possible to have an almost
perfect weak coin flipping
when you allow alice involved to
communicate with quantum messages okay
so this is one of the few things that we
know how to do
we know how to do key distribution we
also know how to do
uh with coins okay
yes so i will say it again so the way to
get an optimal strong
coin flipping is to say that give me a
black box of an almost
optimal almost perfect weak coin
flipping i can use it actually in a
classical
reduction and give you uh
an optimal strong coin flip protocol
okay
so the magic here is
the monotonous magic it's uh it's very
simple to get this once you start from
this thing okay it's very simple to see
that
it is the case okay so why should we
care about this
coin flipping so as i said it's one of
the few primitives that we know how to
actually do
okay so what i want to say that there is
life beyond qkd
so usually when we talk about phantom
crypto we stop at qkd there are other
things that we can
study and things that are possible the
other reason is that there are some
really really beautiful techniques that
go into these things these are
the things that started by kitaev we'll
go through
i'll try to give you a as much an idea
as possible about these techniques
and how you relate all these different
things uh together
on the other hand we don't really
understand these techniques so there is
this very nice formalist that it was
used to prove this weak coin flipping
one of the question is can we understand
it so that we can use it for other
things as well
so this is what we try to do then as
thomas said
we can use this coin flipping to do
other things so in 2009 we used it to
get the optimal strong coin flipping
two years later we also use it to get
the optimal quantum bit commitment
protocol so both these things
use a weak coin flipping as a
as a subroutine this one in a classical
way this one in a quantum way in some
sense
i thought that we just thought we knew
that we couldn't do bet commitment
optimal i didn't say perfect so we do
optimal bit commitment
the probability is 0.73914
something some root of a polynomial yes
yes
so these guys have constant biases
right okay and the other thing is that
there is
there many people in foundations but
also from computer science that we try
to understand quantum mechanics
coming from a point of view of
information right how can we see
uh quantum mechanics as a theory
information and one question that i
would like to understand is that why do
we live in a world where you can do
these primitives which are quite
simple with these weird constants i mean
why is it that the constant for
stronghold
flipping is 1 over square root 2 you can
say the same question why this is to say
it is cos square pi over eight
where do these things come from and does
does they tell us anything about quantum
mechanics
okay that's a very very good thing okay
so why am i here after uh
seven years from monson's result to
explain mozart's result
so mozart's result appeared in 2007.
it's not very constructive as we'll see
at the end of the talk
it's still not very constructive but
it's not very constructive meaning that
there is a proof of existence
uh it's not a probabilistic method that
there is really a construction but it's
not like i can tell you
this is what alice does in ground one
this is what bob does in round two this
is what alice does in round
easily three there's a principal reason
why you can't i mean if you would say
phd student here for
two years uh write down the algorithm
would it be possible because there's
something
so i don't know where you find your phd
students but they cannot put mind for
two years to do this
the information is all there there is no
efficient way of constructing it
that's all i'm saying yes so you can
read you can look at the proof
it tells you how to find the protocol
okay
but at some point you need to find some
matrices of large dimension you know
that they exist
so you have to try them out and see
which one is good and you can verify
that we might not be able to build it
even with patients
so yes so we'll see we'll see what we
mean with this
the second thing is that it was long it
was very technical and actually it was
never submitted
never peer reviewed and when we
had our result in 2009 the first
question that everyone was asking yes
but
do you really think that the mutson's
result is correct
so it took us a few years but now we can
say that okay
yes we do believe that the result is
correct
so we started working in 2010 a long
time ago and these were our goals we had
to verify the proof we have to simplify
the proof we have to understand the
proof
and find a single protocol so four year
latest to
last night at 11 40. have we verified
the proof
yes have we simplified the proof
at least half you know it was 80 now
it's 40 but
there are main parts of the construction
which are simplified there are other
parts that are similar to what mojon
was doing it still needs to be
simplified more
that's why i'm trying to you know
involve you into
this do we understand the proof
better than before have we found a
simple protocol
we have absolutely no idea how to do it
so
we're just starting and
you know we need more people to
to work on this carlos is like our
gracious parallel
say it again is like our gracious
pearlman
exactly maybe maybe the opposite since
yeah since he went through distance
instead of since instead of you know
living in a shack
right went to work for the issue right
yeah oh yes
yes i forgot to say that the problem is
doing finance or something and he has
stopped caring about this a long time
ago
so that's kind of part of the problem as
well
okay so what i want you to understand
from the beginning to the end of the
talk is the following there is one way
of talking about protocols which is the
usual way that we think about protocols
you have two players you have some
hilbert spaces
and at every round of the protocol
someone does some
quantum operation in his part of the
space then the other one does some
operation on his part they go on for a
bunch of rounds
at the end they measure something and
they get an outcome okay this is
just an interactive protocol this is how
we can define
a coin flipping protocol okay
now here's another way here is a plane
and here are some points on the plane
they have coordinates
0 1 1 0 they have some weights the
weights are always
probability distributions so i have
these points and what can i do with
these points i can move them
i took this point i split it into two i
put some new coordinates and new weights
then i can also take a point and i can
move it upwards
i move it up then i can take the two
points up i merge them into one
i take another two points i merge them
and i end up with the final point
what did i show you i showed you the
existence
of a weak coin flipping protocol with
bias
1 over square root 2 because if you make
this equal to this
then you can take u to b 1 over square
root 2.
and not only that i showed you a proof
that this is the bias so the whole point
is to say that instead of trying to find
the protocol and trying to find
a way of analyzing the strategies and
finding the cheating probabilities
there is another formalism which is very
nice to start playing with you have
points
weights on the points you move them
around with some rules
and at the end you look at your final
point and you say these are my
cheating probabilities and as long as
you follow the rules
this gives you the proof that these are
this is the cheating probability that
there exists
a weak coin flipping protocol exactly
with the cheating probabilities
so you shouldn't understand what's
happening here the whole point of the
talk is to to
to go from this formalism into this
formalism
okay and then i guess the second part is
to show that there exists
something of this form where this point
is arbitrarily close to half half
okay this will tell you that there
exists a protocol where the cheating
is almost non-existent okay
okay so how can we try to do this this
has absolutely nothing to do with that
well it's not revealed so this is where
the beauty of keytime's formalism comes
into the picture
here are some of the things that we're
going to use we're going to start with
protocols and cheating strategies
we'll start talking about semi-definite
programs and duality of semi-definite
programs
then we'll go to something that will
need a lot of help
we'll go to infinite dimensional convex
cones
then we look at operator monotone
factions then we'll start taking duals
of cones dual of duels of cones
dual of dual dual okay only we'll only
do it twice
then we'll use some catalyst things and
at the very end
this will show the equivalence of the
protocols and this point games
so the goal is to go through a little
bit through all of this and try to give
you
the main ideas of what goes into these
things okay
so as i said these are some really
amazing stuff we don't
understand them very well we can tell
you why it works we
can tell you some intuition why it works
but really they're just
it's the point where we should start
understanding why they work and how we
can use them further the second part is
to show that uh
this is what monson did that there
exists this point game these point
things that move that go to this point
half perception half perception
okay this will conclude the problem that
you can't do
a weak coin flipping with epsilon equals
zero
yes this goes back to myers in lower
child
and one thing we will we will try to
study as well is
what are the resources we need for this
epsilon how do the resources of the
protocols
scale sorry
yes so there is a lower bound on the
number of rounds
so what we know is log log one over
epsilon
so if you see our rounds you'll see the
difference between the rounds we need
them the log log one over epsilon
okay so
so here is how the proof will go
so we'll start with defining the
protocols and writing them down as sdps
and
dual sdps okay this is the first part
the second part is to try to define some
point games with some
rules on how to move these points on the
plane
and these rules will have to do with
matrices with positive
semi-definite matrices okay why because
then we can relate it back to the sdps
the stps will give us some matrices
we'll define
how these points move around through
these matrices
okay so we'll see exactly what this
means and then
we'll end up with this point games where
the rules have to do with matrices and
semi-definite constraints and we'll say
still we don't know what to do with them
so we'll try to define a different type
of point games and to go from here to
here
is where we use this topology and the
geometry of
sets and cones okay we end up with this
where the rules now of the point games
will be very simple
it will say i give you a function verify
that
the sum of the values of the function
and all points is 0 something like that
something that you know how to use
okay then we'll do another step and then
we'll
yeah okay there are many steps so let me
start before uh
so we start with trying to see why the
protocol can be written why the cheating
probabilities of the protocol can be
written down
as a semi-definite problem okay so let
me
write down again the protocol this is
the protocol we have three spaces
this is alice this is bob and this is
the message space
we start with the all zero state
and at every round alice does something
on her workspace and the message space
then this message goes to bob then bob
does something
on his space and so forth what they do
is just a unitary operation
and we have to add these projections but
for now just forget about them
so at every point they do it unitary
okay
so the initial state is some state size
zero the honest states we define the
owner states
after each round to be psy we have this
unit that is that either
alice in the message or mobile message
and
what do we know about the the outcome at
the end this is a
this is a honest protocol which means
that this is the projection that
alice output zero and this is the
projection that bob output zero
and this probability is half so the
probability that the honest protocol
they they both agree that the output is
zero is the same as the probability they
both agree that the outcome is one
and it's half okay so this is what
defines a
pro weak coin flipping protocol
um you say that you want exactly one
half in the honest case
yes um uh does this also hold for all
the negative results
because i would be okay with something
which in the honest case is a very small
bias
and so if you could get for example i
don't know a strong point was
with negligible bias but also in the
honest case
that would be perfectly nice no
it depends on who you talk to but i
think the honest probabilities will
appear in the lower bound in some sense
if you say that you wanted the honest
case that this is one then there is a
protocol
that's output one so the classical
results that i know
they also hold if you say the owner's
probabilities so so you have some
relation to all the problems there is
there is a relation between the the
honest probability that you put here
and the bounce you get on the cheating
also yeah
for example okay
so this is the protocol and now what i
want to say
is that don't get scared this is very
simple i write down
an sdp that captures the cheating
probability for bob
okay so what do i do what did what will
bob try to do
bob will apply not the honest operations
but some other operations
and what this is trying to do is that at
the end of the protocol he's trying to
maximize the probability that alice will
output one
because one means that bob wins okay so
what are our variables our variables are
the states that alice has
during the protocol okay but what bob is
trying to maximize
is the probability that when alice will
make her
final measurement she will get one which
means that bob is going to win
and there are some constraints about how
these
these states can evolve during the
protocol so what are these constraints
the first one says that in the beginning
is the state psi zero
and then it says that when alice
is moving when is the round that alice
is doing something alice is actually
performing the correct honest
uh unitaries which means that
the state evolves according to the
correct the honest unit that is you
okay and what happens when bob is moving
then we don't know what bob is doing but
what we know is that
bob does not act on this space
which means that if we look at alice's
part
of the state it remains the same okay
this only means that bob's operation
does not touch
the part of alice during the even rounds
okay
so this is the sdp i'm trying to maxim
i'm looking at states on analysis side
so that at the end she measures one with
high probability
and the states evolve according to the
constraints of the protocol
alice honestly applies the use and bob
applies whatever he wants but he doesn't
touch
alice's place uh does this
uh all uh where in this is it that
uh the operations that bob does are
unitary and so on
or don't we include them i mean i i
forgot okay raw are quantum states
if you want
okay they're positive
okay so i can write the same thing
for alice what is the problem is that if
i try to find what is okay
this is what i want to calculate i have
to go over all protocols
i don't know how to go over all
protocols because this is a maximization
thing
okay so what do i do when i want to go
from maximization to minimization then i
just look at the dual
okay so i'm not going to go precisely on
how you go from the primal to the dual
this is
just semi-definite programming quality
but what happened
the maximum is not overall protocols the
first maximum is for a given protocol
you maximize over all
all things it's it's overall cheating
strategies for
bob it's not the protocol it's the
cheating strategy you're right yes
so the thing is that if i want to find
what is the maximum i have to look at
all possible cheating strategies for bob
which means
all all these possible laws that and i
have to find the maximum one to say that
the bias cannot be more than something
sorry isn't that an
like small sdb there's nothing you don't
need to
go over larger and larger matrices right
the
the raw of alices are fixed size
they're define the protocol yeah
so i don't understand is this the
well-defined sdp or you need to submit
yeah
this doesn't search for search over
protocols right
first you have to fix a protocol so what
this tells you is that if you give me a
protocol
i can try to find the maximum cheating
probability which is
i have to look over all possible
matrices
raw which means overall possible
cheating strategies for bob and then i
will tell you what is the cheating
probability for this specific protocol
which is some sdp
this is an sms that's all we're saying
if you want to calculate the cheating
probability for a given protocol
you can solve an sdp but you don't have
an upper bound for bob's
size right so your variables are
analysis part
so this is uh as what he said is that
this is fixed from the protocol the very
largest right because you don't know
of course it's like then of course you
don't know how to solve it yes but uh
okay so just so the use of fixed from
yes the user the protocol the protocol
tells you what are they used
you also know how many rounds you're
doing yes you also know the rounds of
the protocol
yeah so just to clarify oral question i
think
what iodine is meant is is that a for a
fixed protocol
it is a simple sdp
to find the cheating strategy but if you
want to find a protocol with a good
pb star you have to minimize over all
protocols
okay so how do we define the dual
well okay so what are the constraints
the constraints will be matrices now
okay for every constraint here you get
sorry for every constraint here you get
a variable the variable will be matrices
the matrices will be positive you get
some constraint about how these matrices
go from round to round and what you know
is that
again for odd rounds this relation has
to do with these unitaries
for even rounds these matrices these
remain the same and you your initial
condition here that your initial state
will try zero kind of translates to the
fact that the last z
is the projection the honest projection
at the end of the protocol
okay and we add an extra constraint that
doesn't going to change the
the value of this program which is that
we ask that the z
the first zero has actually
this psi zero as an eigenvector okay
with eigenvalue
beta are you going to give us an
interpretation of disease in terms of
the protocol or is it important
so it's not obvious
there's this you should think of them as
projections but even that is not correct
okay and what they're trying to do is
kind of
capture how much the cheat how much
cheating is going on during the protocol
so i think it will be a little clearer
just in the next
slide okay
okay okay so the first thing i want to
say is that
okay so let's try to understand what are
these
these right so what would be a solution
to the dual a solution to the dual will
be a set of matrices
z and for alice and n for both okay i
forgot to say that there are there is
one dual for bob and one dual for alice
so
let's say we solve both these duals we
get
the sets of matrices which are solutions
how what do these things tells us what
it tells us is that they give us an
upper bound on the cheating
probabilities
right so this dual feasible point which
is just the sets of matrices that
satisfy the constraints
of the dual program is actually a
witness of the security of the protocol
okay because if you see here what we are
saying
is that pb is the minimum overall z
of the projection of of this psi zero
on this zero okay so if i find any z
that satisfies this constraints this
will give me an upper bound of this
cheating probability
okay so this is better than the primary
that says that
if i want to prove that the protocol uh
cannot cheat more than something okay i
can solve the primal or i can go to the
dual i can
find the solution of the dual and then i
get an upper bound on this thing
okay okay
so so what i will need to keep
from this from this uh sdp is that this
matrix is
z okay and what i care is how this psi
zero actually projects onto this object
think of it as an object of this
observable
okay okay and here is
uh what is the problem with the dual why
are we not happy with the dual because
here as
it said this is for a specific protocol
again so if you give me a specific
protocol i can give you about on the
cheating probability what we really want
now is to find the best protocol so we
have to go over all protocols so
that we don't know how to do it so we
want to move away from these
sdps okay so what is the next thing is
to go from these saps to this point
games
okay
so how do we do that so i showed you
what is a point game
what is a point game is something that
has some points with some weights
and they move around and at the end they
end up in one point
okay so let's try to give to start
giving a definition of what the point
game is
okay what's evm
oh expressible by matrices oh i didn't
put it anywhere okay
because the thing is that we want to
relate this point games with the sdps
this
what we will relate it to is this feasib
is this dual feasible point these
matrices
so basically we'll use the constraints
that these matrices have from the dual
to say something about how these points
are going to move around
we'll associate to these probability
distributions matrices and we'll have
constraints on these matrices that's why
i mean you'll see that's why we call
these games expressible my matrices
okay we'll see what stuff but there are
sub sorry is there a subset of point
games or it's
do you actually mean the same first of
all i mean to this point i haven't
defined the point game
right okay if if the point game is
points on the
distribution points on the plane that
they move around
yes this is a point game this will be
a restriction of these point games we
want to put some rules on how these
points can move around
right so this is exactly what we want to
say
i just want to know if in my mind i
could think of this as being twin games
even though
you haven't defined them yet oh yes this
is yes yes these are points this is
yes this will be equivalent to the the
very end yes
yes so these are the point games we want
to look at okay but we want to define
them
okay the point is that we want to define
them in the way that they're equivalent
to this
uh dual feasible solutions so that when
i look at the point game
i will get a security witness about the
cheating probability of the protocol
right
so somehow i need to relate these things
okay so let's start
defining the things that we already know
so what is a point game
it's some distributions p0 p1 pn
okay the distributions all points into d
in two dimensions this is what we've
seen and
you know what we'll see is that or
take it for granted we always start from
a uniform superposition of the point
zero one
uh uniform superposition a judicial
distribution of the point zero one and
one zero
this kind of corresponds to the fact
that in the oldest protocol
with half probability alice wins with
half probability bob wins
and the last point would be some bet
alpha point and we want this to be
a witness about the cheating of the
protocol so we want beta to be an upper
bound on the cheating of pope
and alpha to be an upper bound of the
cheating of alice
okay and now we want to add
more things so that this is actually
true
okay so there are two questions that we
should ask
first of all what are these points and
what are these weights what do points
represent what are these weights what do
these weights represent
and the second thing is that how can we
go from one distribution
to the next one okay so i should tell
you
what do these things represent okay and
what are the rules to go from one
distribution to the next
okay so as i said the points in the
weights will come
from these dual feasible points and the
only state of the protocols okay
so what is the dual feasible point is
this matrices z that satisfy the
constraints of the dual sdp
and what do we know we know that the if
i take
the projection of size 0 on zero then
this is an upper bound on pb
and the same with zb is an upper bound
on pa
so kind of what we really want to look
at is the projection
of of the states of the honest states
when we try to measure them with this
observable zens
okay so really what we're going to look
at is the
this quantity this is you know
this is exactly the quantity that kitaev
used for the
strong coin flipping lower bound maybe
zeff will have something to say about
why this is what we
want to look at and how it relates to
other things
but the idea is that what we are looking
at is
how the other states are projected when
we kind of try to measure them with
these zens
okay and what we need to make sure is
that we look at the cheating
probabilities together
if i just look at one sitting
probability i can always find the
protocol that has
deceiving probability equals to half the
other one will be one
so somehow we need to take care of the
cheating probabilities at the same time
okay
so the way we do it is that instead of
looking at the identity identity and the
identity identity z
we're looking at this operator here
which is z and then f
is m okay so we put the two z together
so why is this a good thing to do
because if you look at the at the
initial state psi zero then psi zero is
a separable state
where so this thing is actually a lower
an upper bound on the product
of the two things okay so this thing
here for psi zero
is the product of this times this okay
so somehow it makes sense that this is
what we want to keep track on
at the end this will gives us this will
tell us something about the product of
the two probability of the two cheating
probabilities
okay however this
this product structure is not true for
general science because these are not
separable anymore
but okay so this is the quantity that
we're trying to
represent in these points on the plane
and how do we do it
well the points are just pairs of
eigenvalues
so this is a positive matrix this is
also a positive
matrix let's look at the eigenvalues of
these things so z
i are the eigenvalues of this zb are the
eigenvalues of this
so the points on our plane are just one
eigenvalue of the first one and one
equal value of the second one
okay and how are we going to keep track
of this quantity the weight that we're
going to put
on this point is basically the
projection of the honest state
i on the corresponding eigen spaces
so there is an eigen space that
corresponds to the
eigen value of z a i this is the
projection onto this
eigen space so what i'm putting as
points
as pair are pairs of eigenvalues of
these two matrices
and what the weights are are just the
projections of their own states onto the
corresponding eigenspaces
so somehow what i keep i need to keep
track of these ends
and what i'm saying is that the only
important thing about this edge is
basically the eigen values
and how the honest states project onto
the dragon spaces
i don't really know i don't really care
what the eigen spaces look like
or what they are or where they are but i
care is that what are the eigenvalues
and what is the the projection into the
corresponding eigen spaces
okay so now you know what is what are
the points and what are the weights
yeah can you think of this your magic
quantity as a
some kind of a potential function
throughout your product yeah yeah yeah
so what you say is that
in the beginning you know that this will
is equal or
give you something like that for n you
will know something because the z dens
are the honest projections of the
protocol and you want to see how this
moves from round to round so the idea is
that in the beginning
this starts with the points 0 1 and 1 0
what bob is trying to do is move it
towards
a point where his his coordinate is high
which means that he can cheat a lot
but what we'll try to do what we'll try
to say is that
if we pick these heads correctly then
you can always move this point closely
to half and half
okay but yes it is it is a function that
we know what happens in the beginning we
know what happens at the end and we know
how it moves because of the constraints
of the semi-definite program
this is what will happen okay
all right so i'm very late
but at least i hope you understand what
are the points of this point games
pairs of eigenvalues what are their
weights take the only states and project
them on the eigenspaces
and now what i need to tell you is how
much how can i move from this
distribution to this distribution
and this basically will come from the
fact that i have these constraints on
these ends
okay so for example at every round only
alice is applying the
operation or only bob is applying an
operation what this means if you look at
the constraints of the dual
is that from the i minus one round to
the i round
one of the two z matrices either for
alice or bob is the same
what does this mean it means that the
eigenvalues remain the same which means
that the points cannot move
anywhere but they can only move either
horizontally when one is moving
or vertically when the other one is
moving so i cannot take two points and
move both coordinates at the same time
this comes from the fact that either ali
supplies an operation or bob applies an
operation
okay so every time i move to a different
distribution it's like a round
in the protocol one player applies
something
so i know that the points will move
either horizontally or vertically
okay so that's already there's something
about what kind of transitions we can
have
and the second thing comes from the fact
that i need this matrices to satisfy
this
this constraint which is just the
constraint of the dual
i will see how to uh
express these constraints in a sense
that it would be equivalent to this
thing
this is what the goal is
okay so now i can actually define what
are ibm games
the distributions i start with this i
end up with this
i can only move horizontally or
vertically and this is the constraint
that
i had so let's try to pass it this is i
think the hardest part of the
talk but i okay so what does this mean
what kind of distributions do i allow i
allow distributions on points
okay i look at its line so here i
talk about two coordinates but as i said
points will only move one coordinate
so i can fix one coordinate to be always
something i only look at one coordinate
and how it moves so what it says is that
the weights i can assign
into these points x must come from some
matrix
x okay and the weight
the points correspond to the eigenvalues
of this matrix and the weights
correspond
to the projection of substate psi
onto the corresponding eigenspace okay
how did they come up with this this is
exactly what i was saying that comes
from the
z's and the and the dual right so what
i'm saying is that
the only distributions i allow are
distributions for which
the points are either values of some
positive matrix
and the weights are the projection of
some vector psi
onto the corresponding eigen spaces okay
i do the same
for p i plus one because each
distribution is like that
so there are two matrices x and y
and the extra thing is that
x must be smaller than y okay
in the positive semi-definite way why
should this be the case
if you roughly these x and y's are the
z's
and this constraint is exactly the same
as this constraint okay one needs to
prove it but
i'm not going to prove this part but
the reason we defined it like them is
because they come from this matrices
they constrain that x is less than y is
exactly the constraint that comes from
the
dual sdp okay
so with this definition what have we
shown
basically we have shown that this kind
of games where
i have points that move but they move in
this specific way
are equivalent to having a protocol
and a dual feasible point meaning a
security guarantee for the cheating of
the protocol
so this is off the one hour right
because
come on i'm kidding
i'm kidding
at some point and maybe this is where
it's happening there's
something where the protocol is
disappearing so
when you wrote down the dual no you the
protocol is kind of still
here going from this to y means some u
it's this but what about
just forget about them for now just this
is a joke okay so u
is something that the protocol is the
use right the protocol is defining the
unitaries that alice and bomb too okay
here there is no u but here yes x and y
are not z by n z minus one z i and z
minus one conjugated by the use okay
i'm just just for the big picture we you
you had a protocol and from the protocol
you defined your dual
and your dual variables and then you're
telling us what you really want is to
find the protocol so you know at some
point
the protocol disappears then you're sort
of searching for it i mean
transition from x to y if i give you x
and y
you can find the z's okay
you can also find the use because the
use is just
the change of bases that takes the i can
basis of x to the eigen basis of y
now you're saying you're defining a lot
of the transformations on these dual
variables
such as if you follow these allowed
transformations then
they'll actually always exists a
protocol for which
yes yes and this is the part which is
not
constructive this is exactly the path
which is not constructed
this says that if i give you a proto if
i give you a game like this that follows
these rules
okay if i also give you the matrices x
and y
and psi that verify that this thing is
actually
a good game expressible by matrices then
there is an efficient way of getting
disease which means the security
guarantee
and the use which means the protocol
okay
however what this says is that
there exists x y and psi says that this
is true okay at this point and this is
the problem with this thing is that the
only
way we
know on how to find an ebm transition or
try to verify
it is to try to do a brute force thing
of looking at the matrices and seeing if
if they do if they exist and satisfy
this constraint
is there an sdp to find the matrices
no i'm not sure i would say no but
okay no
no then it would be efficient okay it
could be a largest
okay so
okay so the point is that i define the
game like this
precisely because i want wanted to be
equivalent to this
dual feasible points right and the
protocols
and i tried in high level to convince
you why this definition is equivalent
because this x and y is roughly
your z's and this use is just you can
also find the u from
this x and y so once you know a game
like this
you are able to construct a protocol but
not only a protocol also
the dual feasible point that will tell
you what is the cheating of the protocol
you don't even know the dimensions of x
and y right no limitation
okay i'm skipping many things you do
have
bounce about what this x and y should
look like okay
i mean i haven't put everything yes
okay so we are done with this part of
the
proof as you see there is a lot to go so
what i try to convince you is that there
is a way of going from duels
to this point games but this point games
that are still not very easy to use
these point games that
have to do with these matrices okay so
now what is the
the next part of the proof is to find an
equivalent characterization of these
matrix constraints
okay and this is the point where we use
this geometry in these cones
okay so
this is the part that is quite different
from what motron did
not in in the following sense he did he
does use operator monitor functions he
does define valid functions
but these things are not defined as dual
of something or the dual of dual or
something
and when he tries to prove it he kind of
has in mind that there should be an easy
geometric proof that should work but he
says i don't know how to do it so here
is 20 pages of integrals and
perturbation theory
so this is the part of the proof that
has gone out and i will try to give you
the simple argument that should work
and how we actually make it work okay
because it's very simple and obviously
doesn't work but
you tweak it and it works okay so the
first thing is that
i was talking about probability
distributions that one goes to the next
one to the next one to the next one
so forget about this transitions let's
talk about functions so what is the
function just take
the difference uh of one with the
previous one
okay so if i have a transition between
distribution p0 to p1
let's think of a function p1 minus p0
okay so whenever i give you transitions
you can look at functions whenever i
give you a function
then you can look at the positive part
of the function the negative part of the
function
and this will be an ebm transition if
this is an ebm function then this will
be an ebm transition
so you can go back and forth between
these transitions
ebm transitions and the cbm functions
okay why do we do that because functions
we can actually work with
so these functions are from
zero to infinity to r and they have
finite support
so yes so let's define something more
vigorously what is our space our space
is the set of functions from
zero infinity to r they have finite
support
this is an infinite dimensional vector
space that is the l1 norm
and the basis will be just the the
chronicle basis
okay not important
the argument is still simple the
argument is said let's look at the set
of the cbm functions
okay we can prove that it's a convex
code
very good news it's not closed
not so good news it's infinite
dimensional
we saw things that happened in every
dimension so
but what is the idea the idea is very
simple i have a set
and i want to find a different
characterization of the set so what do i
do
i look at the by dwell i look at the
dual of the set and then i look at the
dual of the world
and this will tell me something about
the set i started with okay
this is the whole part of this proof
once you understand this then
you're done okay you need to prove it
but here is the idea
this is the set k we started with these
weird functions cbm functions
the miracle that happens is that if you
look at the dual this is something that
is very well studied
and the dual of this set is just the
operator monitor functions
what is an operator model function it
preserves
the
if for two matrices x is less than y
then f of x is less than f of y
okay so it's monotonic when say it again
ebm function is just a function
where if you take this it will be an ebm
transition
an ebm transition is just what i defined
okay
so there's nothing between the function
and transition think of them
this is exactly what they defined before
it's the things that come from this
distrib
the distributions and points that come
from these matrices
okay with these constraints now i don't
want to deal with
matrices so what i do is that i take
this set of ebm
functions this with finite support
and i look at the dual and what i can
prove is that the dual is isomorphic to
the set of operator monitor functions
okay there are two really cool stuff
about this
the first is that we know which are the
operator model functions
they're not that many you can have the
constant function you can have the
linear function you can have one more
little more weird function
but we know these things okay so what
does this mean it means that if i look
at the dual of
the operator monotone functions and i
call it the set of valid functions
okay i'll just give it a name then a
function is valid
if and only if for any operator monitor
function
this simple condition holds
okay take the function h
just sub up all the values of h of x
times f of x and if this thing is always
non-negative
for all operator monitor functions then
this function h is in the set
caselessner
okay this is just the definition of
duality i had the call i took the dual
of the call this is just
the duality over the points in the
support of h
yes which has finite support that's why
it's a sub yes sorry
so yes this x is in the support of h
okay
so what does this mean though i know
what this f look like
so i can equivalently write down this
condition as something very simple
a function h is valid if these three
conditions hold
if you sum up the x's on their support
then it gives you zero if you sum the x
h of x then is positive
and for every lambda this guy has to be
positive
okay so what did we do we started with a
set of functions that you have to find
some matrices and some vectors that
satisfy some constraints and we have no
idea how to do anything with them
and we said that basically if you look
at the by dual of this thing
it's something which is very easy to
describe clear functions
with finite support that satisfy these
three constraints
you should probably say that this
characterization gives you these female
ways of the dual cone and therefore
it's so easy right the batia this
characterization theorem for operator
momentum functions
it's exactly the stream of rays of the
dual code
it's exactly there the extrema race
extreme rate
yes so right these lines which
so what i showed is that this k star
star has a very nice
structure i didn't show that k star star
is actually
k and this is not true so k star star
is basically the closure of k okay
because
you need to take okay this is what valid
by the by dual is the closure of the
initial set
okay so these valid functions are very
nice
they're equivalent to the abm functions
up to this closure problem
but intuitively they should be bm
functions
or they should be approximated by ebm
functions okay this is the the main
idea okay
so maybe i skip this part jamie will
give you more examples of point games
i'm just saying that there is simple to
see
some transitions that are valid because
all we have to satisfy is these
things so for example you can move a
point into two points you know exactly
what the weights and the points
have to be because you have this
inequality you can raise something
you know when you can raise and all
these things so this was the whole point
that we go to a point game where you can
see
that it's valid okay what i haven't
showed you is exactly how to conclude
this argument that this k
and k stats are roughly the same thing
so if k was closed then we will be done
because the closure of k is k
so valid functions will be exactly ebm
functions
but we are not closed even if we're not
close if we're in finite dimensions
still would be fine
because what we can define is basically
the interior
of k star star and the interior of ke
and if these things are convex with they
are
if if i have two sets where one is the
closer of the other if i take the
interior of more things then they're
equal
okay so this is the interior which is
which we call strictly valid
where the difference is that we put a
strict
uh bigger than zero instead of bigger or
equal
this you can show that in finite
dimensions is the interior the interiors
are the same
and the interior is inside k so what we
saw here is that this
slight subset of okay i'm not saying
anything what we saw is the strictly
valid functions
are ebm functions okay we didn't show it
because we're not in finite dimension
but this would be the argument that
would work in finite dimensions we're in
infinite dimensions so if you look at
the interiors of these things they're
empty
so even though this is correct we proved
nothing because we say the empty set is
the empty set
still we can what we'll actually manage
to prove is that
really strictly valid functions which
are defined by this
r in k and the way we'll do it is that
by looking at close subsets of k
and showing that these things are in
some close subset of
of k so they aren't okay and the last
thing to finish this part is that the
strictly valid functions
can be approximated by value functions
okay
so what we said is that we started with
ibm functions we have no idea how to
deal with them
we look at the by dual it's a very nice
set
because it goes through operator monitor
functions so it's easy to understand
what kind of functions are valid and we
saw that basically
instead of talking about dbm functions
you can talk about valid functions
okay so now we have this
new games that are very nice because we
can verify what is the problem with them
well if i won't buy an epsilon i will
have an exponential number of
transitions in one over epsilon
so you have to go and express a number
of times and check that each one of them
is valid
so that's not so nice okay so there's
the last step that we will do
which is to get rid of the ordering so
so far we are keeping
the ordering of the transient of the
functions or the transitions we say you
start with p0 then you go to p1 then you
go to p2 and so far
okay so what is the last part of the
thing is to say that okay
forget about the ordering i don't care
about the ordering so what do i do
i just define a time independent game
what is a time independent game
take all the functions that are
horizontal and just sum them all up
and make one function out of this this
is the age and take all the valid
functions that were vertical
which is what bob was doing and sum them
all up
and come up with one function which is
this one this is the vertical one
the good thing about these things is
that if all these things were valid then
this thing is valid
okay so the variant what we really want
to prove
in order to say that there exists a
protocol with cheating probability beta
and alpha
is to find only two functions h and v
which are valid and satisfy this this
thing
okay so the only
important thing about this part is to
say that instead of
looking at this ordered number of
functions one after the other that has
to do with the rounds of the protocol
what we do is that we get rid of this
and we smash everything together
so that's good about finding a protocol
finding a point game because this is
much easier
but going back from this to a protocol
becomes much harder
why because you lost the ordering
but still you can prove that you can go
back if i give you a
time independent game with final point
this
you can go to a point with transitions
which is almost as good and it has a
number of rounds
okay and the number of rounds will be
important because this will be the
number of rounds of the protocol
so we need to keep track of this okay
okay
so what is the problem with this there's
no problem so now
two minutes i will show you how to find
this thing
okay for me the important thing is done
because what i really wanted you to
understand is that what are these point
games
where do they come from and what do they
mean okay
their points the points are eigenvalues
of the
matrices that come from the dual sdp the
weights
are the projections of the honest states
onto the eigen spaces with these
eigenvalues and how do you move them
you move them by some conditions that
come from
the from the operator monitor functions
okay
because we know how to characterize this
operator model function
so that's all so you have a simple
way of trying to find a game
so this is what mozart did the game is
horrendous
and we don't understand it it's not
something which is simple to describe
but in the one minute ahead it's going
to be the following i start with the
2.01 and 1 0.
the first thing i will do is that i will
split this point into a large number of
points
same way i will split this point into a
large number of points okay
the weights will be defined by this
function split j
okay what i would have to prove at some
point is that this split function is a
valid
function okay the second thing is that i
will have to move these points into two
points
and this is the more difficult part i
will have to do
a big construction here use different
points on the
plane and somehow try to move them here
i will explain
just 30 seconds about this and then if i
have these two points i just raise the
macbook and i get to the last point
so this is nothing so there are two
things i need to show this split
that is valid for some parameters
and that this transition here is a time
independently
so just one slide about what is this
intermediate part that starts with these
points and ends up with these points
well we cannot just take the points on
the axis and move them into two points
we don't know how to do this
the only way how to do this is by adding
new points which we call like a catalyst
points
that in their presence things that we
didn't know how to make
transitions that you didn't know how to
make now become possible
so there's this effect that if you don't
know how to go from a to b
you know how to go from a plus something
to b plus the same thing
so it doesn't even change it's a real
catalyst okay
and then you have to see how can you
construct this catalyst and the thing is
little by little
and this little by little is going to
take them many rounds
okay and this is what mutual found
so if i define my age in this very weird
way
says that you don't understand what it
means
then everything is valid and it works
okay
it's magic but there is something that
you can use
you can use the very nice lemma that
says that okay
there is a way that i know that if i put
weights like that
then i know that these things are are
valid
the way and is with some polynomials so
what the lemma says is that
if i use a polynomial with certain
properties
in order to put weights on my points
then by default this is going to be a
valid thing
okay so this is why we use it and this
is what he proves
if i take this omega what is omega is is
my grid
is my discretization of the plane if i
take this to go to zero
and if i take this gamma which is the
last point
that i use fan away to go to infinity
then i can have final point which is k
plus one over two k plus one
this is half plus k okay and this is my
last line
okay last slide so what did neutron
prove because this is new in the
thing what we do so what did mozam prove
is that if we take this parameter omega
and gamma one to go to zero
we want to go to infinity which means i
have infinite far
points and infinity close together then
i can i can prove a protocol with
arbitrarily small bias what we have to
do
is to take specific values for omega and
gamma because this is what the rounds
are going to depend
on prove the same thing do a few more
pages of calculations
and find out that the number of qubits
is fantastic
to get biased epsilon you need log one
over epsilon q bits
and the number of rounds is horrendous
it's one over epsilon to the one over
epsilon
that's it i'm done thank you
sorry for that one or two questions
okay kind of crazy question um we've had
a bunch of talks earlier about
generating randomness with two people
who don't trust their devices and now
this is a talk about generating
randomness with two people who don't
trust each other
yes so is there any hope of combining
these two things
i mean one way of seeing weak coin
flipping is
if you want to see it in a more quantum
way what happens is that you create an
epr pair
you managed to create an epr pair when i
want zero and you want one
and somehow at the end we have a not
really but you do have a
zero one plus one zero that tells you
who won so
in a very high level which is not even
clear that it's correct you are
managing to create entanglement
okay your okay if you want to see it
work classically you do
you don't create a random beat right
this is the difference between
strong and weak on flipping it's not
that the bit is random at the end
is that i cannot buy ac towards one side
and you cannot bias it towards the other
side
so there is this slight difference which
is not the same as
strong conflicting is impossible so it
is a big difference between
getting a random beat or getting
something that each one of us cannot buy
us
but towards one side and towards the
other side
okay so here each party at least needs
to trust their own quantum computer
right yes oh yeah yeah yeah
it's not a device independent protocol
you're only
looking at the input the password i mean
we don't even have a protocol let alone
a device independent
so yeah
so okay let's think